hello and welcome back to 8701
um in this class we'll talk about spin
um if you remember the discussion on
relativistic kinematics we had
last week you notice that
i discussed a decay
of a pion say a neutral ion
into an electron and a positron and an
electron
um and we were able to calculate the
velocity of those two particles the
electron and the positron
quite easily by knowing the mass of the
pion and the masses of the electron and
the positron
you put yourself into the rest frame of
the ion and you can calculate those
velocity
i also told you that this decay is
highly suppressed because of the spins
of the particles involved the pion has a
spin
zero and the electron and the position
have spin one half
but it is not easily possible to align
the electron in the positron such that
the spins align
to zero so therefore this decay is not
easily possible let's dive a little bit
into this
um in quantum mechanics the spin of a
particle
of a particle with a vector can is
quantized in terms of its length and its
components
we calculate the length of this in
vector s we find that the square root
of s times s plus 1 in units of h bar
the component then along the any axis
actually
and in this case here the z-axis have
eigenvalues
and we you know they're listed here um
and we find that there's two s plus one
possible values
so i'll pick here just arbitrarily the
z-axis
but the question is an obvious question
um
which access is a sendable choice for
this problem
so i want you to actually stop here
and think about this what are sensible
options
you know if you want to get an
eigenvalue the physical states of
particles
um which axes are the right ones to
choose
or sensible you know there's no right
and one in this discussion
let me motivate this um if you look at
the orbital momentum of a particle
that's given by
r cross p where p is the momentum vector
of the particle
so now if you're looking at the total
momentum we have to add
the longer the angular momentum and the
spin of the particle together
so as shown in this picture here
you see that the parallel component
the component in parallel to the fly
direction
is zero by definition because the cross
product
is defined the longer
the angular momentum is defined as a
cross product is momentum
so this is a nice choice of coordinate
system or of
axis namely that the choice of the
momentum of the particle
so you find that the total momentum
perpendicular
is the spin of the particle
perpendicular
and the transverse component is the
angular momentum the orbital energy
momentum and the spin of the particle in
transverse
direction this then immediately gets us
to a new definition
that of helicity you can define the
helicity of a particle
as a spin of the particle dotted
with the momentum of the particle and
then normalized by the momentum
so you basically um for a fermion
which has a spin one half get on plus
one half
if the spin points in the momentum
direction
and minus one half if it points in the
opposite direction
so now if you go back to our particle
here
of pi zero decaying into an
electron and a positron
um spins a one half but you find that an
electron
is a left-handed particle so its
helicity will point in this direction
and
for the positron sorry for the positron
it bounces interaction
so the pion here is spin zero
um and you know if you discuss this in
the restroom of the pion
the electron and the positon fly off in
opposite direction
and which means that the spin doesn't
it's well it doesn't align to zero so
that's why this is highly suppressed
um it's not zero um because you can find
you can put step into rest frame where
you're just basically looking
both particles from one side that was
coming to you
and in that case it's allowed but the
spin configuration is highly surprising